[Music]
thousands of years ago our earliest
ancestors might have picked up a pointed
rock and spun it between their hands to
bore a hole in something they wanted to
modify today you can buy drill bits in
all shapes and sizes drill bits are
often associated with carpentry but from
electronics to surgery tooling there are
all kinds of fields that require
ultra-thin high-performance drill bits
the production process begins with
lengths of 100% carbide called blanks a
diamond grinding wheel lubricated with a
specialized cutting liquid is applied to
a chamfered edge on one tip of the blank
this step removes the rough edges left
when the blanks were cut down to size a
vibrating device organizes the blanks
inside a rotating bowl the vibrating
action shifts the blanks into
single-file so they can proceed one by
one to the next step this machine is
called a centerless grinder the blanks
move between two rotating drums which
grinds them down to a specified length
the blanks pour out of the machine
immersed in the lubricating fluid an
operator selects one and places it in a
quality control gauge to check that it
meets the manufacturer's required
tolerances the blanks now enter a CNC
Rolo Matic an operator sets up the tool
and programs its work process a robotic
auto feeder picks up the blanks one by
one from a specialized pallet the
robotic arm places each plank carefully
and precisely in a waiting chuck or
collar and then moves them back into
position the tool moves forward holding
the blank perfectly still as a pair of
wheels close in liquid coolant pours
over the blank as the wheels precision
pinch grind the tip of the blank
grinding it down to about one tenth of a
millimeter the width of a human hair
it's a delicate process the Rolo Matic
produces 48 pieces per hour next a
technician places small sheets of
plastic foil in a jig the foil is shim
stock color coded according to its
thickness the jig raises the metal
support to a specified height when the
blank advances over the support a mark
left in the blue ink determines whether
the metal blank is centered once
complete technician uses a magnifying
tool to fine-tune the placement of the
blank and ensure that it's perfectly
centered this process can take four to
five hours
the blank is finally ready for the
crucial fluting process that will
transform it from a cylindrical length
of carbide with a narrow tip into a
micro drill bit after hours of
preparation this operation takes just a
few seconds an industrial grinding
diamond wheel has sliced a microscopic
groove at a precise angle the technician
inserts the bit sharpened first into a
precision machining device a steel
bushing with the brass insert holds the
tip of the bid in place as a cutting
wheel slices an angled point it's
impossible to see the difference between
a bit before and after fluting using a
magnifying device the technician
conducts a quality control check of the
bit as the screen reveals the finally
cut flute the technician ensures the
tools parameters meet manufacturing
standards
one such parameter has to do with the
shape of the flute which has a forward
taper this means the flute groove
becomes shallower from tip to base at a
very precise angle this feature
simultaneously strengthens the tool
while increasing the chip flow along the
groove although carbide is incredibly
strong when it's milled to the thickness
of a human hair
it becomes fragile needless to say
careful packaging is extremely important